um
[Music]
chew [ __ ] off or i plant my blade in
your ribs
i really think you're fast enough for
that blade
i see it be smoking hole in your chest
before your neurons
light up but hey nothing like a little
experiment
right all right
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
punk what what just happened landed in a
little trouble
cleaned up god damn i'm sorry
i think i've had a little too much [ __ ]
what a night
why why did you help me
izzy would've caught it or worse
this [ __ ] town these people just here
minding my own business if it weren't
for you i'd
here for your trouble the rest
bartender got the rest
circling him like sharks
how about we dream
won't say no to a free drink the good
fortune
and prosperity long day could say that
again
i'm on a double break working overtime
to make an extra buck
nah just don't want to go home
10 years man you know 10 years and
suddenly i'm not good enough
oh she has to go get some side action
anyhow since you brought up money
you wouldn't be looking for a gig would
you be
hey
run me through it it's about my wife
right name's cynthia
she's cheating but i'm
work
where'd she be now she works nearby i'll
give you the address
knowing her she'll be on a small break
smokes like a goddamn fire fire
like happy city wait
today she was wearing a pink jacket
and she had a blue purse i think
colorful always like dressing up
get a woman something nice for her
birthday anniversary
and what do you get in return
why you want to know who she's with
what's the point
what's the point what kind of gunk
question is that
simple one answer it i want to look him
in the eyes
ask him how he feels [ __ ] some other
guy's wife
breaking up a happy marriage
sure she's cheating let's start with the
fact that she always stays late after
work
i know she's lying called her office
when she wasn't even dead
besides that well we got a kid together
right
doesn't even look like me different hair
different eyes all used to be easy to
check these things
but with today's tech there is a way
around every test now
okay fine your mind means a lot to me
but now it was he who needed to get
something off his chest
it was the same old story an unfaithful
wife
in a city where everything was uncertain
you about done i'm trying to focus
what it was her the lady in pink breaker
of hearts
framed by a halo of cigarette smoke i
followed her
dreaming of the day the narrator put a
[ __ ] plug in it
decided to step on her foot don't know
why
guess they don't call me a gum shoe for
nothing
doesn't even make sense
[Music]
there's
oh
the woman looked around something
weighed on her
maybe it was my gaze keep this up
i'm a [ __ ] puke narrate that
what the nerve
oh seriously what what did i ever do to
you
welcome welcome
look
[Music]
the dame disappeared into the guts of a
building ready to collapse
the air hung heavy with smog
maybe it's a good thing i'm dying hey
you
what are you doing here [ __ ] cynthia
told you to make sure nobody followed
you
husband sent me suspected something
see who's right no it's it's not like
that i
i can explain go on then let's hear it
okay for one thing he's not my input
he's my ripper a specialist in plastic
surgery
a specialist in this dump look
i know i i had this little accident a
few years ago
the victim well the patient's family
still can't let it go
that's why i'm forced to work here hold
on a second
what about your kid here's the thing i
oh i didn't used to look like this
i had a total body sculpt skin hair eyes
everything except well
you can't fool your jeans that's why our
son looks different than pepe imagined
it's not because he's not the father
just that i
i don't look anything like the old me
why why do that
and why do you think out of boredom
because i was a
rich basic [ __ ] everyone's got their
own secret
something they want to forget or leave
behind them
i i had a lot of them and i can't share
them with anyone
not even my own husband i know i should
have told pepe about all this but
there was never a good time and now that
i'm expecting again it
wasn't planned please
uh tell him tell him that yes
i don't know i don't know what to tell
him myself
that i'm really sorry that life's an
absurdist drama okay
just just go hit the nail on the head
with that last point
don't walk
job's done followed your wife went into
some run down pad
man was waiting for her inside
i knew it what else knew it huh
didn't know a thing didn't cheat on you
at least not in the way you think huh
what way then
she was out of rippers getting a scan
her skin
hair eyes it's all implanted
every single last part of her so
my son that's why he
exactly chris who's [ __ ] crystal
how could you keep this from me our own
husband then
[ __ ] cares it's not about the skin
or whatever it's that she lied
how the hell am i supposed to trust her
now
okay yes cynthia was hiding something
from you
yes she lied but the woman loves you you
gunk
you know how much that means in this
[ __ ] town if i were you
i just live and let live you know
yeah yeah
i guess you're right anyway thanks
this is for you what are your troubles
good man pepe
take care silence fell like a wet
blanket over the city
muffling its cries time to rest
i thought time to drink
see that's more like it finally making
some sense